I thank you all so much for being here
with us this morning as you all know
Georgia is the state that values life we
protect the innocent
we champion the vulnerable we stand up
and speak for those unable to speak for
themselves
the life act is very simple but also
very powerful a declaration that all
life has value that all life matters and
that all life is worthy of protection I
understand like the others have said
that some oppose this legislation I
realize that some may challenge it in
the court of law but our job is to do
what is right not what is easy we are
called to be strong and courageous and
we will not back down we will always
continue to fight for life I'm signing
HB 481 this morning to ensure that all
Georgians have the opportunity to live
grow learn and prosper in our great
state through the life act we will allow
precious babies to grow up and realize
their full god-given potential
I want to thank Speaker Ralston
lieutenant governor Duncan for their
strong leadership at this state capitol
and on this issue
I like others before me stand here to
applaud representative ed Setzer and
Senator Renee Unterman
for a job well done crafting this piece
of legislation and champion this noble
cause I want to also thank my floor
leaders representative Terry Rogers Jody
lot Burt Reeves Dominic LaRue kia
senators blake Tillery and brian
Strickland for their hard work in
helping secure passage of the life fact
and finally I want to thank those behind
me into the side of those in front of me
those outside of these doors and
throughout Georgia who refused to be
silent on this issue who rejected the
status quo who believe as I do that
every baby has a right to life but
remember today is just the beginning
folks we have too many children that are
stuck in foster care the adoptions
process while we've made great strides
in Georgia we have more to do because
it's still too expensive and too
cumbersome for Georgia families the
elderly are being exploited and abused
in communities throughout our state and
our nation in countless victims of human
trafficking remain in the shadows they
deserve justice that is why we must all
continue to fight we must protect life
at all stages we must weep we must
remember our higher calling and we must
remember to work in the days months and
years ahead as we have done this year
thank you all and God bless you
I'm looking forward to signing the House
bill 481 the life that
[Applause]
[Applause]